coronavirus would be the best thing that
happened to this country welcome to the
program everybody I am 100% in support
of a full-scale pandemic of coronavirus
in this country get people off the
streets out of the malls into their
homes get them [ __ ] out of their cars
close the schools and make the kids
shoot their families and not each other
I think it would be a great change of
pace in this country for a worldwide
flu-like pandemic to hit I'm in support
of it I look at the cases every day and
I get angry there's not more everybody
go in their house and start a podcast
that's it there will be nothing left the
economy will collapse everybody will
come either a podcaster or a cam girl or
boy and you'll either diddle yourself on
camera or you'll yell into a microphone
and that's how this society should
should appropriately disintegrate with
everybody sitting in front of a green
screen Ben and me have talked about this
this is how it ends
everybody back into the house in front
of the green screen live-streaming and
broadcasting that's it and just delivery
people that that brave the elements to
deliver us our pokeballs and our general
towels chicken that's it that's exactly
how the American experiment should end
with everybody in their home ordering
rogue casters and microphones and
headphones from Amazon have them being
delivered by drone and live-streaming
and deciding who's responsible for the
pandemic is it Jews is it [ __ ] Leah
no is it the [ __ ] deep state who is
it is it the Chinese the Tchaikovsky us
and we could spend the rest of our lives
theorizing about why exactly this is
happening what a great opportunity to
blitz put enough with the pop-up stores
and it's an experience we're having an
experience we're filling these little
boots with cheesecake
enough go home lockdown I love that idea
no more fun experiences no more you know
vacations you can't go to Iceland
anymore and swim in a hot spring and put
it on Instagram you can't stay in an
igloo
you have to just stay in your home and
then you you the only money that you'll
ever make now because you can't go
outside the only money you're ever gonna
be late makers and super chats
livestreams patreon subscriptions a
limited selection emerge that's
available because we'll have
self-driving cars that is it and I'm so
excited for that I'm excited for that
and I think everyone should be too let's
finally do it let's finally sever our
selves from the remaining bit of reality
that we live in which is really just
annoying reality's just annoying now
traffic and weather it's annoying shut
it down black out the windows that's the
move I mean think about it you so much
of what we do now is online so much of
who we are we're just creatures that
respond to stimuli that's delivered to
us through our devices why have you know
this fantasy that were you gonna go to a
national park one day and we'll hike up
a hill
stop it means nothing nature's fake and
it's annoying go into the darkness and
stay there put up the green screen you
broadcast nature behind you we have
opted for the darkness because we knew
it was coming
we knew coronavirus was coming you don't
think we you don't think we have a
[ __ ] little studio like everybody
else the cash app is shoving cash up
their ass so they have a cute little
studio look it's so cute we will edit
that out if they invest they are not
sponsoring us yeah we will add it that
out then gives me a locally wait a
minute but not yet they haven't so what
we've done is we have the darkness now
and if you don't like that if it's too
you know if audible.com doesn't think
this is suitable content well then [ __ ]
off it doesn't matter soon it's not
gonna matter soon because it's all going
to be burning and
graves that's right I hope I'm only
nervous I get very nervous that this is
actually being hyped and inflated by the
media and that none of the you know
ideations in my head will come true I
hope that that's not the case but there
is there is an argument to be made that
actually maybe the media's hyping this
up and this is more of a flu and the
people that don't have already
compromised immune systems ie
you know not the elderly or children
probably won't be that affected by it
that would be the worst case scenario
the best case scenario is within two to
three months we're starting to see lock
downs we're starting to see travel bans
we're starting to see schools closed
governments closed you see a little
civil unrest on the edges on the margins
you know a couple of Molotov through the
window nothing coordinated yet because
we need time and then you know it
becomes like the stand the Stephen King
miniseries which I enjoyed was my father
in the 90s to stand we watched it every
night and my father looked at me when I
was a child and he said son this will
happen one day he was great he was
really good at his job and parenting he
said to me oh those a child's like eight
or nine watching this and he goes this
is what's gonna happen and they loaded
up everybody on military vehicles and I
was excited then I said well that sounds
good you know that sounds good you know
that sounds like a nice fun development
even then I knew that this was probably
heading in the right direction so every
now and then like will we get a SARS or
an avian bird flu I kind of get excited
and it always turns into nothing it
always turns into nothing swine flus
nothing ever everything's fake but I
mean it could be real fun because you
know and a lot of people are watching
this probably you know just seems a
heartless and cruel no I don't want
people to die I've been clear about that
I just don't want them to leave their
homes I want them to fully integrate
into the darkness that we are in right
now I don't want anyone to die I need
listeners I'm not an idiot
I need people listening to me what I
don't need is people stomping around
outside outside is the enemy that's
where the diseases
you go back right in your hovel and
listen that's right that's right Jimmy
Fallon and James Corden they love to do
their shows from maybe their homes and
they have massive estate so they can you
know that Jimmy found could still do the
Muppets and his estate cuz he can't
leave and Gordon can still you know with
the top hat and a cane whatever he does
they can all still do that in their
homes you know I just I just think
that's gonna be great then there's gonna
be people you know without shows and
they'll be listening but I think
everyone will start to have a show
that's when you know things are gonna be
good when when everyone that you've ever
met is sitting at their kitchen table
eating cereal in front of a green screen
and just ranting and I mean they haven't
showered in days they've ran out of
antidepressants they're screaming and
they're screaming into the void I mean
you can see there's sunken in eyes and
they're emaciated they're starting to
lose weight because there are shortages
now of course food shortages and and
they're drinking and you know whatever
they keep whatever drugs they can get
their hands on and they're starting to
hallucinate and their shows are getting
really good you know they're getting
really good watching someone to generate
on air is actually very entertaining
it's very entertaining to watch somebody
lose it
marble by marble it's fascinating it's
actually a great watch you know it would
be much better instead of having the
Tonight Show they should have a
schizophrenic at progressively more
insane every single day and that would
be much better you know I mean so that
that's where I'm at with coronavirus I
don't know what's gonna happen
I'm unaware of what's gonna happen I'm
just saying let's not also let's look at
the benefits there's a lot of benefits
imagine this did you see the checkpoint
in China when the guy tried to get
through it they just threw a bag over
his head and threw him in a van
imagine that happening on Melrose at a
sneaker store they just start bagging up
those little kids those hypebeast who
wait all day to buy supreme sweatshirt
they just start bagging them because
they refuse to checkpoints they bag a
little [ __ ] and put them in take him
out get him out of here that's a good
thing that's not a bad thing I think
we're being a little that's just
again maybe maybe it's I love the people
on cruise ships for getting it I've a
bit about cruise I have a bit about
cruises in my act there is no type of
vacation that more defines the fat
boomer generation than the cruise a
disgusting floating toilet where fat
privileged pigs can sit and eat and
drink and gorge themselves for days and
then show up to another [ __ ] island
where people used to live before they
were cleared out by Carnival and Royal
Caribbean and [ __ ] and they show up
and they just get out and they walk
their 400-pound asses around and they
buy magnets and fake jewelry and they
[ __ ] eat Taco Bell quesadillas and
they think you're having a cultural
experience there's nothing more
quintessentially American and pulling up
to an impoverished third-world country
in a floating country I mean pulling up
where you have there's 60 chefs on some
of these boats 60 chefs you're pulling
up to a country with one doctor and it's
a witch doctor it's not even a real
doctor it's somebody who waves [ __ ]
boom you know
ferns at you when you're sick and and
and so the fact that those people are
being quarantined and they're not
letting the back on the mainland and
they're killing them I mean I just I'm
trying to see the negative in this
pandemic I've been trying to see it I've
been trying to see the negative in this
pandemic all week I have people calling
me concern they're like somebody called
me I swear to God my aunt called me she
goes this is horrible what if you can't
do stand-up comedy anymore and you just
have to do your podcast from your house
but I don't have to walk into a mall and
entertain people choking on chicken
fingers no that's crazy I just get to
communicate with my fans and never see
hear or touch them wow that does sound
like a horror what a nightmare
blink and bring on the bubonic plague
bring it on
you know there are people that have died
now that is sad and I want to say that
I do want to say that I don't know any
of the people who've died I get it I get
that that is sad I don't want to sound
like a total sociopath I'm just saying
there are silver linings to all the
clouds you know the stock market's
losing money that's fun you know I'm not
really invested in the stock market I
don't really care what happens I don't
care so I mean I don't want the economy
to completely tanked and people not
being able to support me via patreon /
the tim dylan show which you all should
be [ __ ] on already because we're
doing great work over there stop
consuming everything for free have some
pride take some pride support your local
artists don't you love when you first
get into comedy you do these horrible
shows and the backs of bars and like
they put they make these flyers these
people and most of these people are
delusional psychopaths who should be
taken out in the street and shot and
there they're you know comedians you
know I'm on Keita it's like we get it
and these people they put on the flyer
like support live comedy and support
local artists and support Lee it's like
what it's just so funny the idea of that
it's like support live kind it's like
people do they do support live comedy
they don't support you they don't
support you and there's no that's
because there's nothing to support
there's nothing to support those shows
should be done in front of people that
are unlucky enough to be boozing their
life away in that particular institution
on that evening that's what it is if you
were drunk and you're not home with your
family you might get somebody yelling
into a microphone in your space that's
what it is I performed in a lot of those
bars on Long Island where people were
just trying to throw their lives away
and I'm like hold on I'm trying to throw
my life away I want to ruin my life and
they're like I'm here to ruin my life
and the quiet you know and it was just
that tug of war of two groups of people
both wanting to completely sever their
relationships with society trying to
figure out who I've watched bars throw
their that like their entire business
model was based on doing open my comedy
and their regulars the only people that
are making money from we're like what
the [ __ ] is going on I just come here to
drink I
come here cuz my local watering hole
it's a gin mill it's a blood box I come
here you know I come here to just
[ __ ] disassociate from my [ __ ]
life and then I have to like be
inundated with a stream of psychopaths
who have convinced themselves that
they're following their dream is there
anything more disgusting than when
someone's bombing in like a bar or
something they go oh and no one's
listening to them and no one should be
and they go oh it's alright I'm just
living my dream up here well then you
have a shitty dream you have a shitty
dream and no one should respect your
dream oh it's just my dream appeared
that's all it's just my dream that's
your dream to stand by a pool table in a
bar and perform to seven people because
somebody told you in the cubicle next to
you that you had something to say you
have nothing to say until the pandemic
where you will make no money unless you
figure out something to say real quick
and livestream it um I want to let you
know that the I'm gonna go on door - now
and see where the Cheesecake Factory
quesadilla order is we live in Los
Angeles there's not a lot of good
Mexican food in Los Angeles so what
we've done is ordered quesadillas from
the Cheesecake Factory because they are
very good and a lot of the authentic
Mexican in LA some of it is good but a
lot of it is dog food and I don't want
to eat lizard meat and you know and the
guacamole is never good it's always a
creamy and it's not you know and some
Mexican here is great but I mean some of
it is just like you know enough already
with it you know and there's nothing
wrong a quesadilla to me feels American
except unless you go to that place the
Deen Del Rey told me about in San
Francisco in the Mission District I
forget the name of it El Farolito
amazing the best steak quesadilla in the
United States of America at El Farolito
and it's nice and you can eat it and
then walk directly outside and watch a
man pick off the rest of his face
there's nothing better than that
you can watch someone take a nice
steaming [ __ ] right on the curb San
Francisco you know so it's really really
it truly
it should be arriving in 30 minutes you
know but I like uh you know there was a
great thread on Twitter about the
Cheesecake Factory it was a phenomenal
thread that somebody wrote it was just
about the aesthetic of the Cheesecake
Factory see if you can find that see
what's amazing about Bonnie's young
Jamie of course would have had it up
already cuz as soon as I mention it he
would start looking for it but Ben then
you have to look directly in his eyes
and say to him in unbroken English can
you try to locate the thing I'm talking
about now to make the show better
because that might be interesting young
Jamie a crane of Rogen's knack or just
of the way Jamie would have it up
already but Ben you have to say to Ben
like Kent hi hi I'm the toast can you do
can you pull it up and I was waiting for
more info you've read it now a
cheesecake fact I know why start typing
in I was very very serious
I was very mysterious when I said a
Twitter thread about the way the
Cheesecake Factory looked the aesthetics
which means the look of the cheesecake
it was very mysterious how would you
possibly know that I wanted you to look
for a thread on Twitter about the
Cheesecake Factory
I should have emailed you I should have
done show prep which I refused to do
because really to be honest [ __ ] you
people oh we're heading into a pandemic
ok I've been on shows where they do show
prep their nightmares ok can you read it
yeah this person deleted their threads
so I know are you serious yeah but I
found it on Mashable so let me see if I
can this is the I wonder what corner the
Internet bends down like this I don't
know if this is clearly the thread that
I'm talking about like Benny's found
some thread where some guys like I was
sitting in the Cheesecake Factory and I
started thinking about different
cultures developed in different parts of
the globe which me and I'm like no
that's not it it's about the way it
looks but it's I think the argument is
Cheesecake Factory is the most American
restaurant in the country which I think
it is I don't think that other than
McDonald's I don't know if there's an
argument that there's any other
restaurant that is more emblematic of
our failed experiment then a restaurant
called The Cheesecake Factory a factory
I mean it's just an amazing
so the Cheesecake Factory essentially
grew out of a Los Angeles bakery
business then in 1992 they brought on
hospitality to designer Ric McCormack
and [ __ ] went off the rails we're
talking Victorian Egypt
Rococo off the rails I mean check out
this exterior greco-roman cornices am I
saying that right cornice cornices cor
okay seashells above the pseudo arced
doors topped with a dome airlifted from
[ __ ] Saint Basil's the interior is a
world of aesthetic chaos that feels like
a mix between a Fry's Electronics and
overgrown panera and a laser tag arena
it's sensational
palm trees set aside to thousands chic
glass lighting fixtures French limestone
floors mosaics fresco like murals pseudo
Egyptian faces top columns with hybrid
palm frond lotus blossom designs and
pseudo hieroglyphics it's unchecked
white exotics ISM / Orientalism run amok
with a huge budget some elements like
the faces third eye and the so on like
sconces board a lion on a cult flavor
it's really wild now let me ask you a
question can you read can you actually
that was a vet that was it was a lot of
words it was it was a lot it was it was
uncomfortable for me to watch you go
through that they said because he went
to a Christian school where the only
word you you learn at his spell is Jesus
and no that was a good job you did a
good job it's the listen there's a lot
of words in there I get it there's a lot
of different words back to back over and
over again that's the problem
word after word after word after word
but it is crazy like when you were
sitting in a Cheesecake Factory like
this doesn't even make
hence you look around and it is this
[ __ ] why I mean I used to go there
and I would sit there with friends and
you know it's such a big thing in Long
Island and you would sit there and you'd
look around and you would just be like
what is this place
you do they have them in Texas yeah
absolutely yeah everywhere yeah I mean
it's a mall they're always in mall yeah
and they're always massive and I have
these just massive columns it looks like
you're eating in a set from Xena Warrior
Princess you know it's like you feel
like you just be sitting here with a
bunch of guys drinking jug wine and then
scene it would come in and just start
[ __ ] you up except that's not Xena
it's a suburban real estate agent and
she's heating herb crusted salmon which
isn't bad with the lemon sauce it's not
bad it's not great their mashed potatoes
are good because they're filled with
like they just inject them with like I
don't know sugar and fat butter I have a
lot there was I got into an argument
somebody the other day they were like oh
you acted your foodie and everything but
you're kind of white trash because you
like condiments there's this anti
condiment movement going on right now
which I want to address what it was one
of my friend Michael who is genuine
white trash whose nose has this arch in
it listen if you're lowborn
there's nothing wrong with this if
you're a highborn you I of a European
facial structure now many of you don't
notice X I'm fat and but go look at me
when I was a child it's European facial
structure now what that means is I have
an angular face like like like an
Abyssinian cat and Abyssinians an
Egyptian cat and not cars to feared jewy
like where it's sunken in and weird but
I have it was an angular face and then I
got fat so then I got the American pot
like an apple pie fat but that's not
that's not me that's what I've done to
myself so I am highborn now and there's
nothing wrong with that I don't think it
makes you better than anyone but in
inherently and biologically it does
lowborn people my friend Michael has him
knows like I'm trying to look at that
Ben's nose is not bad it's really not
bad it's it's noses are in port like my
friend Michael yours is fine thank you
michael has a
you've seen Michaels nose yeah right
what is it it's that it's like bent it
has a bit of a hook but it's not jewy do
I look those Jews run the world
yeah it's we're not [ __ ] on them and
don't isolate that what I'm saying is
that there's nothing when I see a big
nosh on a Jew I know that I'm dealing
with somebody that's [ __ ] caught in
most cases has their [ __ ] together but
Michael is that he has that white trash
face that as it's kind of a bent nose
where it has like a little bend in the
middle of it and it just screams
working-class it your screams like
you're a nobody
when I see that crooked like bent nose I
go you're onobu you're a factory worker
you're a slob Europe you're punching in
you know and I support all those people
but it just it's you feel II I use I did
they're identifiable and so Michaels
telling me he doesn't like condiments he
doesn't like ketchup but he doesn't like
mayonnaise shut up you know what I mean
first of all the only problem with
mayonnaise is that there's too much of
it
Maness is an essential component but it
can't be an individual it's not supposed
to be a component on the sandwich it's
supposed to be an enhancement so what
happens is because Americans are fat
disgusting irredeemable slobs they've
taken this [ __ ] and then just slapped it
on things and it's gotten bet has all
kinds of flavors it's not supposed to be
like that ah but it's it's there's no
argument against Mayo it's just there's
too much of it and when there's too much
of it it it is gross it is disgusting
but these are all cut ropes for white
trash cut your barbecue sort of mustard
and old stuff what are you saying
what do you shame you know this is a kid
that I got in an argument with because
he said he was gonna pick me up from the
airport picking up for the airport he
offered he said to me I'll pick you up
and drive you to the airport listen to
this listen to this and then after all
I'm gonna give out his phone number at
his address
but listen to this I don't want to
announce these should I say that he's
say whatever you want I can cut it out
if you don't know we're not cutting it
out
he's having a baby okay he's gonna have
a baby that's cool yeah I mean take me
to the airport here's the thing you
offered you offered you said to me I'll
pick you up this listen why doesn't pick
me up this piece of [ __ ] it is a half
hour before he's supposed to be at my
house like 8 o'clock in the morning at
7:30 he calls me I don't answer now I
don't answer because I'm asleep but it
doesn't matter I could have been in the
shower you when you say I'm gonna be
there at 8:00 what do you do you be
there at 8:00 right you don't call a
half-hour before I'm not canceling my
trip you know I need the ride and then
he says I'm not coming I'm not coming
too so I'm like how do I get the kid
back I thought long and hard about it I
was like shut up cause his mom died of
pancreatic cancer last year I'm like
should I get faced her grave is there
waited to face I've never even been
faced a grave in my eye but you could
hire people right to the face of grave
what if you dug her up
I'm just these are the thoughts I'm
having in my head now I understand these
are the thoughts I'm having in my head
what and this is one of my best friends
he's I truly I love the guy and he's
been very good to me I think doordash
might be here he's been very good to me
and I do love him he's like a brother
but I'm like what if we dug up his
mother or to face the grave you know
what I mean put swastikas on it try to
get her kicked out of the cemetery then
I was like maybe because I know as a dad
and I was dad's phone number I loved his
father's father's a great man
could I pay people to call his father as
his mother in the middle of the night
and pretend that it's the mother calling
the father and maybe she's like I'm in
hell what do you do to me I'm in hell
I'm thinking about like how do I
creatively do something because it's you
don't not drive someone to the airport
it's not right mm-hmm
it's not right I confronted him about it
and he's like oh I have uber can you
leave it in there just we're gonna wrap
up we'll eat and then we're gonna come
back and do more
but come here for a second Brian because
I want your thoughts on this what if I
had cuz I was father's number I love his
father as far as a good man but is it
fun to get back at him by having someone
call the father in the middle of the
night as the dead mother and claiming to
be in hell like like she goes yarman so
I'm like she now I'm like now I find I
oh he's having a baby
do we kill his trials like these are all
because you don't not jump to somebody
for the airport what about the dog I
blocked his dog on Instagram
his dog is on Instagram I blocked his
dog because I didn't want him trying to
get to me through the dog right I
started talking to him since then but
he's he doesn't deserve me as a friend
he doesn't deserve a celebrity friend
he's in the weed business which is the
most boring thing ever and he drones on
and on about grow operation no one gives
a [ __ ] shut up Tommy no one cares what
you're talking about at all
with your [ __ ] weed business yeah
you're [ __ ] working for a drug dealer
okay
he's not Warren Buffett he's a [ __ ]
drug dealer and I'm glad that you're I'm
glad
oh and that's every weed company that's
fine I'm glad you're making money doing
it I don't think it should be illegal
but let's not talk about it like it's a
fascinating [ __ ] a bit it's just not
it's not a fascinating bit Oh what do
you love the weed people bought a weed
shut up we get it enough you're a boring
[ __ ] so ugiy is he's just a boring pouty
little [ __ ] she pouts a lot he's always
like you know so he's dating someone
who's gonna have his child who is a in
the dreamer program she's a dreamer can
I get her deport I mean genuinely can I
get her to commit a crime can I convince
her to commit a crime can I go to her to
commit a crime so I could get her
deported these are all thoughts
that are appropriate these are
appropriate sought you can't let people
[ __ ] you
am I wrong here no I didn't do a lot of
this it takes too much effort we put too
much money into the studio I can't hire
people to deface graves I just thought I
can't pay everyone I got too many I'm a
penis guy could barely talk could barely
talk you can't look anything up I should
have him to face a grave I should tell
him that's part of it what he's doing
now you going to face a grave
I've decided not to I've decided to
start speaking it to him again on a
limited basis to see if he can earn the
friendship back but don't enough with
the con tell me I can't have condiments
you know but this is the thing it's like
how do you get anyone back now how do
you get anyone back you can either cut
them off or you have to go big you
really have to go big you know we're
gonna take a break now we probably need
to reheat the quesadillas anyway because
you know it's the traffic in the city is
like you order something you get it
three days later they've eaten half of
it you know what I mean these people all
these a lot of these people living in
their vehicles it's very hard like
they're they're sleeping on a you know a
[ __ ] pizza bar it's like it's a nice
and it's it other nightmare here which
is why what a joy a pandemic would be
what a great change of pace
everybody was like mad about the
pandemic there all the worst people
through all the worse
oh my god I hold the pen I don't know
I'm just sort of sex we're going to
Mexico and it's coronavirus I hope that
it doesn't oh I hope it does it does I
hope you're wheezing on a beach I hope
you're wheezing on a beach somewhere I
hope your girls weekend go south so
quickly I hope you're wheezing on a
beach and I hope that there's [ __ ]
little Chinese guys would [ __ ] you
know like those big [ __ ] bug nets and
they're just [ __ ] throwing them over
you because that's what happened to the
other guy and that that's where I'm
thinking but I'm gonna be friendly again
with with Michael but I think wasn't he
wrong using the wrong completely he
should take you out maybe on a vacation
or you should run
house out in Malibu for the weekend I
think you should go [ __ ] these are good
ideas to win back my French would that
be enough for you something like that no
it would be a start it would be a start
to open a dialogue I think that would be
a start to open a dialogue okay he is
really one of my best friends he's
helped me out when I was like now he's
like me money before when I wasn't doing
well and everything like that but listen
we can't live on the old times
you know what I mean like we have to we
have to realize I did I would feel weird
like going into facing his mother's
grave that would probably be too much
right you think so then said it gets
illegal also then say that cuz he's a
Christian all this mumbo-jumbo believe
in all this mumbo-jumbo when I'm dead
you could I want you to take me out
[ __ ] party on and [ __ ] throw my
fingers in a restaurant and stuff I want
you to take my rotting corpse use it up
political so I don't even have to agree
with I don't even have to agree with
what your stance is you just take my
rotting corpse and go all over the place
with it
I mean I'm for it you know I just hope
that people aren't listening to the show
and they've found out that or they think
that I'm a bad person because I had some
of those thoughts because those are
normal thoughts to have when you are
wronged like that by a friend who says
I'm on my way to work now I called you
you didn't answer I thought something
was up so I turned around and went the
other way what excuse me no good no good
so I thought there would have been
nothing wrong with you know or calling
or I was thinking about accusing him of
rape like as a woman like as a woman
creating a woman or paying a woman or
several women attentively to accuse him
of rape or to call his parents like his
father his brother and say I was
rapes I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna
do any of it because I'm you know but
these are all this is what they call
proportional response
he has your air pods also you know now
that I think about it he still does have
my air pots I had to go buy $200 air
pods I'm gonna deface the gray I think
I'm gonna deface the grave I really
think what if I just write Trump 2020 on
the bread and so people think she's a
trump supporter all right let's go eat
we'll be back all right we're back
everybody I did a spot at the Comedy
Store in LA a lot of fun we are on the
second leg of the show we're slightly
calmer I filled in for a lysis Lessing
her and me and her have different fan
bases so there was a lot of hot chicks
in the show with the boots up on the
stage but it was a great set they were a
fun audience and I'm thankful that I was
you know thanks for putting me in coach
a lot of fun some of the women you know
chatted during my set but I get it if
you come to see her and you see get you
get me it's a little bit of a culture
shock you know I get it
she's very successful she's I don't I
don't I met her once and it was we had a
little bit of uh it was like it wasn't
great you know our meeting it wasn't
phenomenal I don't know you know
I'm not gonna go into it I don't want to
start airing you know whatever wasn't it
wasn't anything memorable she wouldn't
remember me it's just like you know
people said to me they're like you have
any you have any opinion on the Pete
Davidson Louis thing and you know and
Pete specially described I'm like I'm
like yeah I have an opinion on it
they're both millionaires and I'm not
so I'll stay out of that and I'll let
them handle it and I'll ask them to you
know buy me a doughnut you know like the
that that's where I'll that's my
position what's what's your position on
the Louie Dave what I don't know either
of them what are you talking about
they're both doing great
I met a studio here in an apartment
we're trying to we're trying to live
trying to survive I got a [ __ ] decide
which one of them I want to alienate I
support both of them I agree with both
of you fine sirs and if either one you
want to produce anything I'm doing let's
you know Hillary Clinton is starting a
podcast and many people know my affinity
for Hillary Clinton and I don't even
mean as a joke I do respect you can't be
a student of history and not have some
level I don't want to use the word
affection but you you are in awe of
certain people's abilities certain
people's abilities even if they are
murderers even if they have sexual
problems as her husband seems to but you
look at a guy like that it was a Rhodes
Scholar smart guy the human brain is
fascinating some of the most talented
people in the world have things that are
deeply wrong with them Michael Jackson
you know maybe Woody Allen I don't know
maybe
[Laughter]
I you know allegedly like brilliant
people insanely talented people in in
certain cases have real issues you know
Bill Clinton was an incredibly gifted
political mind watch his speeches watch
his ability to communicate with people
he would go into a room and make these
you know single mothers think he gave a
[ __ ] and he wanted to [ __ ] he didn't
give a [ __ ] he wanted a [ __ ] it's a
different it's an amazing skill set and
there's very few people that I've seen
have things that approximate that skill
set up close
some people are magic I've met a few
people that are magic have those
cuadrado Carmichael comedian producer
has a quality of magic where when you
are talking to him you feel like you're
the only person he's talking to or
thinking about or he's he makes you feel
very good now he's a good guy I'm not
saying that this is not you know who he
is but I'm also saying that like it's a
skill it's a skill some of these people
are great salesmen some of them are
great politicians none of the words
because the word salesman makes you
think of somebody like me you know it
doesn't make you what I'm what I'm
trying to describe is hard to really put
into words because it's it's a magical
quality that certain people have star
power or whatever you want to say it's
infectious you want them to like you you
trust them you Hillary Clinton did not
have any of that she didn't have it her
husband had it Hillary has a lot of
other qualities she
great deal maker she's a great
behind-the-scenes operator she's you
know a tough [ __ ] she knows how to you
know string up a noose metaphorically
but Clinton was elected the governor of
art you know he went to where did he go
Georgetown Yale Harvard Oxford Yale
Oxford Georgetown his mentor's a guy
named Carol Quigley who wrote a book
called tragedy and hope which is this
huge epic history of the world in our
time talks about you know the eastern
establishment the anglo-american Empire
everything it's really a history of
everything you know people have put it
you know as uh you know it's like
they've said the genre is you know
conspiracy literature but it's really
it's it's much more than that
it's really an amazing compendium of all
of these councils and all of these
groups of people that have shaped and
continued to shape the world and that
was Clinton's mentor and Clinton was
elected to governor of Arkansas I
believe 31 he was like the boy governor
he was a young governor right about the
time the CIA was flying you know planes
full of coke and a Mena Arkansas and
dropping off that so that we could put
it into inner cities and fund the
Contras
it was you know that's there's so much
evidence of that and Clinton was you
know like hey you know kept his mouth
shut
there were two boys who were hanging out
down by where one of those drops was
happening and I think their name were
like Kevin Liles and Don something I
don't know the boys on the tracks
was the documentary about it or the film
about it and they and they were
somewhere in the secret airfield or
wherever when they were they had
witnessed something they should not have
witnessed and then like many young teens
do they ended up smoking marijuana and
falling asleep on the train tracks
well I've smoked a lot of weed and I've
never fallen asleep on the train tracks
but this is the story you have their
names Don Henry and Kevin Ives yeah
Kevin Ives and Don Henry and they ended
up you know falling asleep on the train
tracks and getting killed nobody bought
this but you know they witnessed
something they shouldn't have witnessed
this is when you know and his Clinton
the governor at this time I'm pretty
sure he is yes he is yeah Clinton's the
governor of Arkansas during this time so
again this is you know his bona fides
are established here he then is mentored
and guided you know then he ends up I'd
like to build a bird conference again is
the governor of Arkansas what is the
state of Arkansas I have to stay about
International Finance not much but he
ends up there and then he ends up
getting elected to the presidency twice
and defeating George HW Bush friend of
the show than many episodes on him
many episodes on the Bush family don't
worry about them they get a poppin you
know yeah there's no shrinking violets
over there they're deeply connected much
deeper than the Clintons the Clintons
were like trash you know in in the sense
that they were you know being you but
the people that make the Clintons lie
can I do it too as a joke you make them
like into a boogeyman they're not
running the show they are there they're
a moral people that is why I do it
because I want you to know how a moral
your leaders are but when it comes you
know the bushes were deeply connected to
the intelligence apparatus deeply but
Hillary is now starting a podcast my
friend Hillary I mean I don't want to do
a million hacked
about her podcast it's just here's what
I will say how far the mighty have
fallen
[Laughter]
how far the mighty have fallen from the
world stage from murdering Vince Foster
from arranging the suicides of many of
your Secret Service people from the
Clinton Global Initiative laundering
dark money from all over the world from
the Epstein's from the islands from
little st. James to reading an ad for
blue truth how the mighty have fallen
it comes for all of us at the end
doesn't it folks I talked about it
earlier in the show I watched a little
bit of a CPAC you know the Conservative
Political Action Conference I want to
say this and I want to be clear whether
you are a young college kid at CPAC in
khakis and a blue blazer or you're in
skinny jeans at a Brooklyn DSA meeting
if you are actively involved in politics
when you're young you were a closeted
homosexual that is it if you and a bunch
of other men are going into hotel rooms
to debate each other stop it you're
wrong
you want to suck their [ __ ] I get it I
did it I was on the debate team I get a
bunch of dudes in suits walking around a
hotel showing off their brains their big
hard brains I get it that might not be
all of you but the amount of hot sex
going on at CPAC right now the amount of
people taking balls to the chin after
listening to kimberly guilfoyle news
from that con artist remember her I mean
you gotta respect the level of grifter
and con artists that's at CPAC
she was in gay she was like married to
Gavin Newsom of ran San Francisco he was
the Governor of Cal he's the Governor of
California now he was and now she's
dating Donald Trump jr. and then the pit
stop between those two was Fox News God
loved her
God loved her because there's a version
of her in Tampa getting railed out by a
failed real estate developer doing lines
of coke on her waterfront property
that's really three blocks from the
beach but she [ __ ] her way into the
White House ish they're probably not
allowed in me but good for her these con
artists and the Democrats aren't any
better I mean if you're at a political
conference what are you doing
didn't you hear what I just said about
Mena Arkansas and you think anything
Mercedes slap is saying Google Mercedes
slap who's this who's this broad she's
getting up in front of a conference room
socialism's bad it's an honor to die you
want to know who she is I'd love to know
she is she so I can hate on her she's an
American lobbyist and columnist oh great
she served as White House director of
strategic communications in the Trump
administration since july 2019 she has
worked on the Trump 2020 reelection
campaign these people by and large have
nothing to say the Republican Party has
been devoid of anything listen guys like
Bill Kristol these guys justified
genocide but at least they wrote books
like at least they knew how to speak the
clown car of grifters liars and thieves
that has become the modern Republican
Party is kind of hilarious and you know
listen not that the temp Amin the
Democratic Party I don't have to say
this you have nine people having him
breakdown on the debate stage every
night and and the CIA is and
[ __ ] billionaires send in Mike Mike
Bloomberg who like has far less charisma
than like moammar qaddafi like you know
what I mean like this guy he's trying to
literally steal the election from people
that are Tom Styer is criminally insane
and I support him I'm a stye and but he
just performed with juvenile he just
does a rap thing with juvenile I think
they would do him back that ass up which
is a great song but Tom Starr is a
billionaire he's dancing on the stage
it's a country's a joke it's a literal
joke that you would you would you would
pitch this show in a writers room and
get told to sober up nobody would
believe this
these are billionaires that are bored
and they're getting out there and
performing with rap she go to CPAC
and you watch everybody fight it out
everybody's talking about taxes and they
just want to suck each other's [ __ ] and
why not they find some some drag queen
and went into a library and we're all at
by the way not only am I never seen a
drag queen in a library I've never seen
a library where are these libraries
who's reading who are all these children
being read who's reading where are the
reading programs I mean I've already
thought on record and said that it's it
seems very forced and weird that that
drag queens are in libraries reading
indicates who odd they're in weird
costumes they're not overtly sexual but
in some of these dances they do are
suggestive and strange I don't I don't
I'm like what the [ __ ] I see this and I
have a natural aversion to anything
that's sexually but it's also
interesting that it's being portrayed as
a national epidemic that like it's just
happening all over the place and it's
like and a lot of it is because the
economic policies don't work and no one
could get anything done in Washington
cuz like it's just gridlock and nothing
gets done so you just get a tax cut they
flood the market they they keep the
interest rates low they suppress them
artificially you know I mean it's just
wages don't go up healthcare doesn't get
fixed everything ends up costing more
money there's a certain amount of rage
that people have so you gotta like
directed at the real problems in the
country the drag queen in the library
and Colin Kaepernick because that's what
they're talking about as CPAC those are
the big problems Colin Kaepernick and
the drag queens at the library are the
reason that you went bankrupt three
times because of a knee operation it's
like and and it's just the people that
are at CPAC and I'm not a model but some
of the people at CPAC like the way they
look like the German anti Greta and I've
said Greta is creepy and strange and I
think it's weird that Democrats have no
problem throwing a seventeen-year-old
girl into the ring with Donald Trump I
mean it's barbaric you shouldn't have
kids making points I don't care what
David hog thinks I don't care what Greta
thinks how dare you like I don't I don't
want shield I don't need to be lectured
to by children and I think it's pretty
[ __ ] up to trot children out and let
them just get attacked but this girl
looks I mean Naomi whatever he's see it
I mean it I mean this one she describes
herself as a climate realist has also
had to deny she made remarks that could
be seen as anti-semitic following an
attacked on a on a synagogue last year I
stand her we stand her here now I mean I
didn't know she was real no I'm kidding
I don't know I don't know it she's like
but I have learned about the climate is
the jewel The Jewel will come like she's
at CPAC and she's like they're like
waving her down they're like you they're
giving her the light they're like it's
time to go you know at the end of his
speech she's like the tool comes into
your country
and they start to manipulate the weather
the weather and they're like alright
give her a hand everyone give her a hand
thanks so much fun
can you imagine going to a political
conference what type of loser do you
have to be to be standing in a ballroom
listening to these people speak any
party the same thing with the DSA people
that are in Brooklyn when all that [ __ ]
they can't even afford hotel they could
have their parents paid it's the same
it's like listen I'm not telling you not
to help people but nuts this is not
helping none of this is helping showing
up to the Gaylord hotel hilarious which
is such a trashy hotel my friend Michael
who spoke about him earlier was like if
you go to Dallas you gotta stay the
Gaylord hotel it's perfect it's big it's
ready it's great ask if you look at the
Gaylord hotel they're grotesque
I've been to it it's trash there's trash
they have a big ice sculpture thing you
can see on Chris yeah it's to have a
Riverwalk yeah
San Antonio has a Riverwalk everyone is
seeing Antonia is 450 pounds okay and
they and they scoot down the river and
they just eat churros okay and they
don't share them with the birds the
birds are seeing Antonio are emaciated
they're about to die the birds on the
river about to die because no one throws
them in he bread there's not one card
that gets thrown to a bread at the San
Antonio Riverwalk
so the Gaylord hotel has a [ __ ]
Riverwalk like I'm gonna walk around the
Riverwalk so it's like and I listed some
of the kids who went to see Packer
friends at me on Instagram like one of
this one of these kids I forget his name
he works for like Tucker Carlson's thing
and like when we made the one we made a
whole interview somebody reached out
from the Daily Caller they're like we'd
like to interview I'm like let's not
it's just not you know what I mean
somebody also sent in a request from
like love it or leave it that podcast oh
yeah they're like we want to interview
you I'm like let's not I interview
myself for several hours we're good
we're good that's okay
and then they were like
could you should do a video for us I'm
like I'm just independent we just you
independent videos thank you I
appreciate it
they're not bad kids right they're not
they're stupid cuz they're young and
they don't realize that nothing they do
matters and you I get it
I got it I get wanting to be part of
thing it's the job and it's fun and it's
a convention and it's like I mean listen
we're when we do the convention a real
convention a sales convention in Arizona
and a Marriott for young entrepreneurs
that want to get involved in a new
company called joules by podcaster Tim
Dylan I will show you what a real
convention is okay and it's not
listening to Dan Crenshaw I mean can you
stop war is good I mean what is the
message over there at CPAC what is what
is the message let's just get the last
of earth's resources and have a fun time
doing it what's what's the thesis
statement of of that group at this point
Healthcare's great shut the [ __ ] up
everybody's fine if you have an issue
start a hedge fund
what's the thesis statement any more of
the group you know rupaul's coming to
kidnap your kids Colin Kaepernick's
dishonouring our honorable police who
keep shooting black people in the face
everybody I know in high school that
grew up that used to bully [ __ ]
people is now a police officer everybody
I know in high school it used to she
used to spit in the face of [ __ ]
people now as a gun and I'm we're all
supposed to pretend that that's some
type of a coincidence one guy with high
school is like a baseball guy a bunch of
a bunch of guys that went was gonna be
athletes and that didn't work out they
got injured now they're cops I'm sure
they're not angry
I'm sure they're not mad at all and
listen I'm just [ __ ] on the the
Conservatives because they had the
conference when the Liberals have their
conference I mean god only people like
that you know identifying themselves but
you know what is you Jen you could have
we could have nine nametags will you
prefer gender how far away someone has
to stand when they talk to you in case
you have a breakdown the medications
you're on so that you could leave your
hotel room and function you know how
loud someone can be please don't clap
near me I mean we saw the TSA thing
where they were like that's coming and
I'll [ __ ] on that when it's here it's
just imagine I would like I would it
would end my friendship with someone if
they're like I'm going to the police
I'm going to the political convention
wife yeah I want to go see kimberly
guilfoyle Newsome i want to hear her
take and they just get up there they're
like socialism what is what is
representative Marsha Blackburn from
Tennessee think wise I mean that's the
whole thing over there but there's
probably some really really hot gay sex
happening at CPAC it's just what it is I
guarantee you those Grindr apps are
going crazy because a lot of these very
eloquent articulate young men are gay my
friends are all straight they're
[ __ ] my frança go get my friend and
go ask Michael what he thinks about the
global economy look we'd all the [ __ ]
and weed that's what straight men sound
like for the most part not all of them
not all of them but young college dudes
that are getting [ __ ] do that reading
of unless there's total sociopath like
Bill Clinton and they want to just rape
is what I mean if you're sad if you're
that articulate and you get really
excited like you're on the Speech and
Debate team and you get really excited
and you know a lot of those guys are
like some moral fiber of Americans being
threatened you're like okay you have
come coming out of your ears
the [ __ ] that is to college debate
about politics is like holla it's just
hilarious so like we have to notice that
in the same way that these emaciated
far-left weirdos who can't even come
because they're on SSRIs and twenty
other medications they come dust and
they don't even have sex they just they
just hold somebody else and cry together
and rub their genitals together until
they get warm
it's just how about we tell everyone
under 25 to take a knee shut up
vote vote but go live a little you don't
have to be at the Gaylord hotel
listening to people vote do whatever you
want you know but it's like enough with
the Greta's and the dish so I gotta get
lectured by 19 year old her to climb it
really she's know the [ __ ] you talking
about you're 19 you don't know anything
you don't know that Hillary and Bill you
don't know how they got that's where you
start to you start talking about the
bushes and the Clintons you're kind of
in awe to a degree I'm like these little
piece of [ __ ] at CPAC you think that's
all it is you think that's all it is to
get on a [ __ ] stage and say they're
lotar Luther good know you got a guilty
pow
you gotta kill people are you willing to
kill people you fraud you gotta you
gotta have private islands with
blackmail operations set up you got to
overthrow Dickie you're gonna overthrow
[ __ ] democratically elected
governments and install dictatorships
and you got
all while you're dancing on Ellen you
don't know what it's like you don't know
what the sacrifice is really like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're getting up at CPAC
don't sue them bear couplers are good
you don't [ __ ] know what you have to
do it's like these young comics we're
like I had a good set why aren't I say
miss because you don't know what God you
have to do
Billy Eilish is killing people out there
slitting throats
she's a Mossad agent that's what
frustrates me people [ __ ] on Hillary
you don't know what that [ __ ] did
kimberly guilfoyle news to me with you
at you're a cheap [ __ ] Hillary's a real
bad mm bad [ __ ] she's a real murderer
so I'm just saying these kids don't know
what it is these millennial snowflake
cuts whining about their student loans
don't understand the work it takes to
run this country the dungeons the blood
the narco-trafficking it's not just
going and having a fun little debate at
CPAC and after you do all of that and
after your murder and you kill and your
maim and you torture after you do all of
that
you're still thrown in the street after
you do a Comedy Central special and a
Netflix special and a pilot and you have
another show being produced by a
producer whose name I don't want to
mention because I don't know if it work
with me again probably not but whatever
the point is you're still thrown in the
street Hillary or Tim and what do you
have to do you have to start a podcast
so welcome miss Clinton welcome welcome
welcome this is where we're all at [ __ ]
I know what it is they say you're gonna
get a certain amount of ads every show
and you're not gonna [ __ ] get them
cuz they're lying but you do a good job
on the ads you have you read that blue
to ad you read that ad [ __ ] you get
them to buy the ridge while it's Hillary
because we're all
in the same bag bowler [ __ ] now that's
what it is you were high on a horse
jet-setting arranging executions you're
doing it all you were doing the most and
now you hear what the rest of us with
the Legion of skanks with my favorite
murder with come town with myself you're
here with all of us
you're just you're three years away from
doing skank fest and you don't even know
it
and those people open their arms to you
that's your new fanbase Hillary done
with the global finance and the shadowy
intelligence intrigue goodbye
international power brokers hello
manscaped but that's what it is
welcome to the show Hillary I for one
welcome you I think you've got a lot to
say I think it could be very interesting
don't get a co-host do it on your own
get good learn how to broadcast learn
how to be personal build an empire like
we're all trying to do by podcasting
because that's the only economy left do
you understand welcome mrs. Clinton I'm
honored to have you as a colleague and
good luck